is Russia headed back into another
crisis into another recession so
Russia's heading back into recession
Russia's heading back into a situation
where it's very difficult to control the
currency in fact the outflow maybe not
just the worst since 2008 they may be
worse than 2008 just to give you a sense
of what's happening there um I don't
think we near a debt default but we are
very near a vicious cycle that feeds
financial stability to the economic
instability and back so it's not 1998
again it's not 1998 in the sense of a
default no it's not but it is the
seventh largest economy in the world
Europe depends on exports to Russia
European companies are exposed to Russia
so that is not good news for Europe in
particular that's already facing
headwinds as you mentioned earlier sure
and certainly you're already seeing it
particularly in the German economy the
German exporter is really feeling a drag
coming from Russia can the russian
central bank rescue the rupal know the
russian central back on its own cannot
it needs help from the other government
entities and in this political help you
know if President Putin continues with
his interference in Ukraine we will get
a second another round of sanction
what's called level 3 sanctions which
will target energy and finance and if
that happens then Russia goes into an
even vico recession